steep slopes and narrow alleys have
forced this centuries-old city to hold
on to some of its traditional ways
dating back to 600 bc akra is one of the
oldest inhabited cities in the world and
for generations this has been the only
mode of transport
even bringing home the groceries is a
challenge
every day i use my donkey to transport
household needs and things can't be
carried without the help of donkeys
almost all of the residents of these
neighborhoods own a donkey which is
technically their vehicle that they rely
on
and the most basic services are affected
the municipality decided to use donkeys
years ago to carry out the tasks of
cleaning and transporting garbage from
these neighborhoods our work is
exhausting but it may sound strange to
anyone who hears about it
but even the use of donkeys has led to
charges of corruption
in recent years local officials have
been accused of making money by hiring
donkeys that only exist on paper
and the mayor argues that baghdad budget
cuts have left many public employees
working for free
we had many irregularities many of the
municipality workers including some
animals were paid salaries even if they
do not report to work it became a court
case at a later stage
ultimately many of those workers ended
their employment with the municipality
which has taken a heavy toll on our
operations despite these irregularities
those workers were exonerated by the
court
as for the donkeys they continued to
work
this village's ghost mule employees is a
microcosm of the endemic corruption in
iraq recent research suggests that the
way the system of governance works is
that power brokers accumulate wealth and
influence without providing basic
services to the people
here security forces caught an official
taking bribes
it's an open secret mafias control
ministries and many government officials
benefit
and iraqis blame corruption for poverty
and unemployment
less than half the population voted in
last october's election and iraq still
doesn't have an official government
but while the politicians struggled to
form a government in baghdad across
donkeys carry on their daily tasks
oblivious of the corruption allegations
against them
northern iraq